uh well sources uh here in washington
are saying that it is the al-qaeda
leader ayman al-zawahiri if that is
correct then this is the most
significant counter-terrorism operation
as the americans are calling it since
the death of osama bin laden back
whenever it was a few years back my mind
escapes me at the moment but this is a
very very significant announcement that
much certainly being made clear by the
white house who said that the president
will address the nation at 7 30 uh local
time that's
12 at your time uh tonight so in a
couple of hours at time they they say
only at the moment that that a
counterterrorism operation has taken
place in afghanistan that it took place
uh over the weekend and our um our
colleagues at nbc news uh have say are
saying that two sources um that they
have spoken to have said that it was a
drone strike uh over the weekend and
that it killed uh the top al-qaeda
leader ayman al-zawahiri
an egyptian man a man who took over from
osama bin laden
when he was killed and a man who has
eluded capture ever since he was wanted
for the bombings
not in new york but back in 1998 the
bombings of the american embassy uh in
nairobi and also in dara salam
involvement in that prompted him to be
on the fbi's most wanted list of course
he was a very senior al-qaeda figure in
2001 during 9 11 um number two to osama
bin laden and for the years since osama
bin laden has been dead uh ayman zawa
hawahiri has been the al-qaeda leader so
a very very significant announcement
that we're expecting from the white
house in a couple of hours time